[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, hey, hey, hello paragliding pilots across the world. Welcome to your weekly dose of awesomeness on Paragliding Atlas podcast, the
[SPEAKER_02]: fastest growing show on the interweb for the sport of paragliding. And today we are talking about a topic that most of us are or have been curious
[SPEAKER_02]: about at some time. And that is how to share the absolute magic that we experience in the air with our friends and family and hopefully beyond.
[SPEAKER_02]: And how about this, if I told you that there's one person who has figured it out whether he wanted it or not. And he has figured it out up to a point
[SPEAKER_02]: where it is infectious, and a lot of us want to try and replicate that. Yes, as the name of the episode suggests... We are talking about none
[SPEAKER_02]: other than our very own influencer who has managed to crack the short-form content creation code and relentlessly brings all his
[SPEAKER_02]: adventures to our phone screens time and again, invoking nostalgia, FOMO, and inspiration all in one go. Benjamin is, hands down, single
[SPEAKER_02]: most followed pilot on Instagram, amassing millions of views across his platform for his creative style of storytelling. And the whole idea
[SPEAKER_02]: of coming out with this episode was to try and divulge the details to a larger audience on how he does it, why he does it, and if you're inspired
[SPEAKER_02]: by it, how can you do it? So without further ado, This is not just to talk about how to get likes. Instead, it's a masterclass in passion,
[SPEAKER_02]: perseverance, and the pursuit of stories that inspire. And no, you don't have to pay for it. That's the beauty of it, as it resonates with the
[SPEAKER_02]: whole idea behind Paragliding Atlas, and that is to bring knowledgeable information about the sport at zero cost to consumer. So
[SPEAKER_02]: tune in, and I hope you like it. Oh, and yes, do not forget to like, subscribe, and share to both of our channels, the link to which is in the
[SPEAKER_02]: show notes below, because that is the way we get to spread this awesomeness together and make the whole community a lot more aware
[SPEAKER_02]: about the joys that the out of flight brings in our life.
[SPEAKER_02]: Benjamin Killett, what an absolute honor to finally have you on the show, man. I think I have to tell this to my audiences. There hasn't been
[SPEAKER_02]: an easier guest to reach out to. You replied in five minutes and we are talking in two days from the start of conversation, man. Thank you so
[SPEAKER_02]: much. Love it. No, it's a pleasure to be on here and I love bringing the Stokes community. So I'm happy to do these sorts of things and glad you
[SPEAKER_01]: reached out. So yeah, thank you very much for having me. Awesome, man. But just to start, when you said you love sharing this with community,
[SPEAKER_02]: how did this thought process come to you? Because I think you are one of the most successful Instagram influencers, if we have to put it that
[SPEAKER_02]: way, in the paragliding scenario. How did the thought process of sharing the aerial adventures come to you and what's the meaning behind
[SPEAKER_02]: them? Mostly it started from just, to be honest with you, like I would go flying and I'd make videos for myself. And during the flight, I would
[SPEAKER_01]: talk to add context to the video because otherwise when you look back at, if you're flying and you just take videos of the scenery, yeah, it's nice
[SPEAKER_01]: to look back on. But what I thought was added more value to that for myself was, I'm just going to silence my phone. I apologize. What I thought for
[SPEAKER_01]: myself added more value. Was to describe my thought process during that time and my emotion and how I was feeling and what I was looking at,
[SPEAKER_01]: because I thought maybe if I look back. at this footage and I go, where am I? When was this? What was going on? So I would just tell myself, I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: purely talking to myself saying, okay, so I'm looking at Mount Pollux and I'm thinking about making a glide over here, but I'm just making sure
[SPEAKER_01]: that I can get high enough. It's November, it's 2015 and it's a really beautiful day and I'm happy to be here. Stuff like that. And I do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, and then I look back at it and go, oh yeah, cool. Yeah. Maybe I'll post that on that, that clip on Facebook and I'll do that. And I'll just upload
[SPEAKER_01]: it and people started liking it. And, but mostly it's just for myself, like the thought process stuff. And then I can look back of it and I can
[SPEAKER_01]: analyze. my decision-making, I could look at the flight. Was it a good flight? Was it a bad flight? Where did I mess up? Okay. This decision was
[SPEAKER_01]: wrong. I shouldn't have done that. And then I can look back at my footage and go, this is what I was thinking. That's what was actually going
[SPEAKER_01]: through my head because your, your, your concept, your, your perception of what you're actually thinking changes. over time so i
[SPEAKER_01]: could look back and go okay this is actually what i was thinking and yeah that was incorrect that's i'd made the wrong interpretation of the
[SPEAKER_01]: weather conditions or my expectation of the day and and that's why i made the mistake so it was a learning curve it was for my own pleasure and
[SPEAKER_01]: enjoyment and i i just shared it and i keep sharing it and and i think people like that i think people like to see and the raw point of view, what
[SPEAKER_01]: it's like to be in the moment and in that experience, but also understand what's going through my head. And at the beginning, it was for me. And
[SPEAKER_01]: when I got more experience and I started doing better flights, People started taking things away from that and using it for their own learning
[SPEAKER_01]: experience. And that's my style, more raw. Like it's nice to put up a scenic video of the scenery and some cheesy music every now and again,
[SPEAKER_01]: but more I prefer sharing the emotion, decision-making and logistical side of it. I would say your voiceovers are infectious enough to try and
[SPEAKER_02]: recreate, try and motivate all of your viewers to recreate their own. You're doing something pretty right there. This reminds me of a video
[SPEAKER_02]: review system that we have in a lot of professional sports. In paragliding, we use that pretty heavily. in SIVs, and I always used to
[SPEAKER_02]: wonder that why can't we do the same in cross-country and everything, but I think you are taking a step in that direction, and I understand the
[SPEAKER_02]: battery systems and all of the limitations with the cameras are obviously limited, but I often wonder if we can have a dash cam or
[SPEAKER_02]: something like that on our cockpits, which just records the whole flight for safety evaluation or anything, so... I think this is one step
[SPEAKER_02]: in that direction in new technologies, I would say. Yeah. But so let's say, would you mind talking about your airtime? Like how experienced
[SPEAKER_02]: you are, how long you've been doing this? Yeah, sure. So I started paracliding in 2014. So it's yeah, it's just December 2014. I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: knocking on 10 years flying now. I learned to fly in on Coronet peak in Queenstown. There's big tandem flying community here. So I saw people
[SPEAKER_01]: flying. I had a decision one day I wanted to go and do something new. I didn't zero research. I had no idea what paragliding was really. I just
[SPEAKER_01]: wanted to go and give it a go. But the decision I got was, do you go for a tandem flight or do you go to the school? And the school did an
[SPEAKER_01]: introduction day for the same price. And I said, I might as well go do the introduction day. I actually get to fly the glide myself. And I went and
[SPEAKER_01]: did that. Flew off the training hill five times and loved it. And then they said, if you come back tomorrow, you can fly off the ski field. And I
[SPEAKER_01]: went and flew off the ski field. I was hooked. And I did a bit more research and I found out that you could do long distance, you could do aerobatics
[SPEAKER_01]: and things like this. Yeah, that's how I got into flying. It's basically just from seeing other people fly myself and deciding that I would give
[SPEAKER_01]: it a go. I've been living in New Zealand for... 14 years now i'm british yep so originally from the south of england and i now for the last three
[SPEAKER_01]: years i'm doing six months in new zealand and then i'm spending the other half of the year in the northern hemisphere i work professionally as a
[SPEAKER_01]: tandem pilot that's my day job That's six months in New Zealand. I've worked three months of the year in Switzerland and I'm traveling for
[SPEAKER_01]: about three months of the year. But yeah, as I do also make videos, which is a bit of a side hustle, but primarily my day job is flying tandems.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah. A side hustle made you the most followed person on Instagram. How cool is that? It's like bragging rights for life, man. Yeah, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's cool. It's really exciting. And to be honest with you, it's grown a lot over the last six months. I've honed in my style of video. That
[SPEAKER_01]: seems to be resonating with people outside of the paragliding community. It is exciting. It's layman enough that people that don't
[SPEAKER_01]: fly understand to some extent what's going on as an exciting for them, but there is enough Easter eggs and knowledge in for the people that do
[SPEAKER_01]: fly to get something out of it. But it's very short, like I cram a day into a whole full BIV day, but a lot goes on in a day of flying BIV. cram it into a
[SPEAKER_01]: minute and a half and people enjoy it. But it's grown a lot in the last six months, which is exciting to see. Basically, once you started sharing
[SPEAKER_02]: your flights and narration and all the voiceovers behind it, how did the community start growing around it? Can you take our audiences through
[SPEAKER_02]: early days of how a growth looks like in this perspective? Yeah, I mean, it's just mostly just friends and family, really, that were watching
[SPEAKER_01]: the videos that I was putting up and It was quite raw, you know, in the beginning, because as I said, it's just my emotion and my decision
[SPEAKER_01]: making. But what helped with the growth was my skill as a pilot increased. And when I started flying bigger distances and flying, it
[SPEAKER_01]: was a combination. My skill as a videographer and a pilot grew together. I'm not a very skilled videographer. The more unique thing, I think, is
[SPEAKER_01]: that I'm willing to wear and use a camera and do flights that people aren't normally doing. It's the combination of the two. I was flying
[SPEAKER_01]: lines in New Zealand that aren't commonly flown, but the unique part was that I was wearing a camera and I was talking about it. And, and as I grew as
[SPEAKER_01]: a pilot, the videos got better. I got better at recording videos and that's how it grew together. But mostly it was friends and family in the
[SPEAKER_01]: local community. Mostly people who are very interested in flying specifically in New Zealand, who've got the beta from the lines that I
[SPEAKER_01]: was flying and learning the hard way. Like I did some mistakes and shared it nonetheless. And it was those two things together, I think that
[SPEAKER_01]: really made it grow initially in the very early days. A curious question comes to my mind, and I'm pretty sure this will resonate a lot with our
[SPEAKER_02]: listeners as well. Did ground suck try to pull you down at times when you were putting out your vulnerabilities out to the world? From other
[SPEAKER_02]: people? Yeah. Not so much, to be honest with you. I was quite confident making my own decisions. Always have been. In New Zealand, the
[SPEAKER_01]: community is growing, but it's not a huge flying community. There's not like a big mentorship program, really. Like in other countries, like in
[SPEAKER_01]: France or the UK or Switzerland, where you've got big pools of pilots and you have experienced pilots that you can follow. If you want to do
[SPEAKER_01]: cross-country flight in France, you can just follow other people on a good day. They've got plenty of gliders in the air. You can just go out and
[SPEAKER_01]: do it. Whereas in New Zealand, where I really cut my teeth is, You can't really do that. You have to go and do your own thing. You have to go and hike
[SPEAKER_01]: up a hill, make your own plan and go for it. The community is growing, but it's not there yet. I wasn't influenced so much by other people's
[SPEAKER_01]: decisions. I just was left to just do my thing. I flew with friends and we did some stuff together, but it was, and there were other more
[SPEAKER_01]: experienced pilots that I have flown with, but mostly It was my own decision making and I never really felt too much of the ground suck, as
[SPEAKER_01]: you say. Yeah, not so much. That seems like quite a blessing in digital age. My question stems from the curiosity that social media, by its
[SPEAKER_02]: default design, is meant to dish out gratification and validation and everything. And regardless of how much we try, somehow the algorithms
[SPEAKER_02]: do reach us and the likes and the comments end up affecting us unless we are strong enough to just not press that notification buttons or just
[SPEAKER_02]: check that out. For people out there who are inspired by what you do, and of course, as the landscape is growing with digital and digitization,
[SPEAKER_02]: there will be people trying to replicate. Is there a defense mechanism to try and block away the I can put it in as simply as negativity. Somebody
[SPEAKER_02]: goes out there and says that you shouldn't be doing this in the comments, and you're like, that's his life, but I have to protect mine. So is there
[SPEAKER_02]: anything that you have done which has particularly worked for you, which kept the comments and the likes and the validation that comes from
[SPEAKER_02]: it immune away from your passion? Do you mean doing something in the flight specifically for making a video? Oh. the audience reacting
[SPEAKER_02]: other than planned to your video and you not letting that affect you in the air. To be honest, really, the comments and the things that I get from
[SPEAKER_01]: my videos, 99% are positive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mostly, I'm fortunate. I think generally I'm putting out positive content. It's about an experience, so I don't get very many negative
[SPEAKER_01]: comments. The negative comments that I do get in towards what I'm doing are somewhat unjustified, and it's mostly people that just don't
[SPEAKER_01]: understand. They just don't understand what paragliding is and how it works. I don't think, and I never would, and I don't post videos of me
[SPEAKER_01]: being negligent towards my own and other people's safety i don't think i'm taking any unnecessary risk and posting it online so i'm not really
[SPEAKER_01]: exposed so much to that i think the negative comments that you get from i do get from people from sometimes you just laugh it off because it just
[SPEAKER_01]: it's just people that just don't understand and sometimes i try and educate and i respond to the comments i always respond to i respond to
[SPEAKER_01]: most comments and i just explain to them It's not like that. Like how you get people comment things like what will happen if, are you not scared
[SPEAKER_01]: that you're just going to fall out of the air and die? I'm like, no, because I'm flying. I know. And it's like, it's, that's the only sort of
[SPEAKER_01]: things that I get that in that negative way. Yeah. I'm not too concerned about that. I like to try and educate people that don't. understand what
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding is that's really a big motivation for me is that when people that don't fly watch it and they don't understand but most of it's
[SPEAKER_01]: positive most of the comments are positive of people who don't understand but they're excited to see it and they want to understand
[SPEAKER_01]: what's going on how are you doing this you don't have an engine this is crazy and i love explaining that to people every now and again you get a
[SPEAKER_01]: negative one where people say oh you're not gonna you're not gonna last long they just they just don't understand and that's okay No, that's
[SPEAKER_02]: great that keyboard warriors are sticking to their keyboards and not affecting you in the air. And I think this is a welcome outlook on social
[SPEAKER_02]: media. I was not expecting this because usually social media is a place where people love venting out. But if there's positivity in the
[SPEAKER_02]: community, then that's so motivating, man. Yeah. All right, got it, man. Benji, before I move on to the next topic, I quickly just want to
[SPEAKER_02]: touch upon how did the growth look like with respect to timeline? Because obviously a lot of algorithms and information out there which
[SPEAKER_02]: says how to grow on these channels and everything is you should post at certain things. And from what I see that you were just going out and
[SPEAKER_02]: living your life organically. There was no specific motive in trying and being successful in this direction. However, you ended up doing it
[SPEAKER_02]: as it should be. So just tell our audiences, how did the timeline look like from your posting to you getting traction to finally starting to
[SPEAKER_02]: grow and then the last six months? What's the roadmap to here? I've been posting videos on social media for paragliding since I started flying,
[SPEAKER_01]: which I started flying 10 years ago, but maybe I've been posting more seriously in eight years. But the reality, so it's been a long road, but
[SPEAKER_01]: the goal... has never really been to do anything. I never really, I never started posting videos on social media with this in mind. I posted it in
[SPEAKER_01]: the beginning just to share my experience with my friends and family. And then the paragliding community or that I was living in within New
[SPEAKER_01]: Zealand got interested. And then that kind of motivated me to keep posting more than other people got more interested. So I keep posting
[SPEAKER_01]: more and. It took a long time, but then you go through waves of motivation because then at some point you think, what am I doing this for? And you
[SPEAKER_01]: have to come back to your core motivation, which is I like posting videos that I enjoy to make, that I enjoy to share, that I'm passionate about.
[SPEAKER_01]: and that I think other people might like as well. And if you're not doing that and you're just making videos for the sake of making videos, then
[SPEAKER_01]: it's a waste of time. And I've stuck to those principles since the beginning. And it's just naturally just evolved. I've gotten better at
[SPEAKER_01]: them and more people have gotten interested in them and it's evolved and grown together. But I've been posting for eight years, more or less.
[SPEAKER_01]: After about four or five years of posting, I started generating a bit more of a following on Instagram. My focus in the beginning was actually
[SPEAKER_01]: probably more on YouTube and then The problem, what I did over the last year was stop posting as much on YouTube because the amount of time and
[SPEAKER_01]: effort that goes into making a YouTube video is so much more. It's so much more work making a long-form YouTube video than it is to make a
[SPEAKER_01]: one-minute video for your phone on Instagram, Facebook, TikTok, it takes me an hour, an hour or two to make a reel on Instagram. And that
[SPEAKER_01]: sometimes can reach millions of people. And that has a much wider effect for me than spending a week. Literally, like the YouTube videos can take
[SPEAKER_01]: me a week to make a 15-minute video. And it just doesn't have the same reach. And I'm speaking an hour, and it's just for the balance of
[SPEAKER_01]: lifestyle. for me just making these shorter videos just makes just made a lot more sense for me and that's what i i made that shift about a year ago
[SPEAKER_01]: that i stopped making so much youtube stuff and i started just making just actually just putting more of my time and effort into instagram and
[SPEAKER_01]: tick tock the short facebook short 9 by 16 vertical format videos And they just reach so many more people. And I've had so many people message
[SPEAKER_01]: me and ask me, how do I get into paragliding? And that really motivates me. It's amazing. This is super cool. I don't care about the money that,
[SPEAKER_01]: you know, or maybe I'll get more money if I did the YouTube stuff. I think this is easy, easy. I make short videos. It reaches loads of people,
[SPEAKER_01]: brings paragliding to the forefront. It's cool. And that was the kind of the progression. A quick question comes to my mind when you talk about
[SPEAKER_02]: DMs. How many DMs do you get in a day, man, with that kind of following on Instagram? And how many of them are from women? It's an interesting fact
[SPEAKER_01]: because Instagram does give you quite a detailed analysis of your following, which I look at, and I'm 92% male, unfortunately for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but no, you get lots of, it depends on the month, but you do get a lot of message. But mostly the people that send me direct messages are
[SPEAKER_01]: people that are really motivated by watching my videos and they really want to just know how to start the sport. And I do not mind responding to
[SPEAKER_01]: those messages at all. No, love it, man. I think that there's something with the digital landscape and women consuming paragliding because
[SPEAKER_02]: we, the Paragliding Atlas, hover between 15 to 20% women listeners compared to male listeners. Yeah, so far. But yeah, let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's see who catches up in each other's foray here. That's great. But I quickly want to know, did you see some periods of growth like that first
[SPEAKER_02]: 1,000 was the hardest or first 10,000 was the hardest or first 100,000 was the hardest? Like which one was the slowest and which one was the
[SPEAKER_02]: fastest in the past metrics? Yeah. But if I'm being totally honest with you, I don't know because I, and I'm not trying to seem nonchalant about
[SPEAKER_01]: it, but I wasn't really paying that much attention to it. What I was doing was just sharing videos that I was passionate about. And yes, I did
[SPEAKER_01]: notice when I did gain following, but my, when I was posting videos, I wasn't trying to get more followers. So I wasn't really, it wasn't like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my, do you know what I mean? Like I, It happened and it was probably, I posted a few videos when I had my Instagram account was just starting and
[SPEAKER_01]: I did a couple that I got like a million views on one video and that was huge for me. Like I didn't have that many followers and that it was one video. I
[SPEAKER_01]: just put like a video of me. It was a 360 camera on my head and I flew false on full speed bar down the road. I just flew down the road and I put some
[SPEAKER_01]: catchy music to it and boom, they got a million and a half views and that, and off that. So this is maybe a piece of advice for people who want to grow
[SPEAKER_01]: a social media account in the same respect is that. When I, when that happened, when I got this boom million and a half views, I kept posting. I
[SPEAKER_01]: posted every day. I posted every day for the next two months or something. And I rode the wave and riding the wave. of that one that did
[SPEAKER_01]: really well grew my following. And that's really when I started paying attention to how many followers I have, how many people are following
[SPEAKER_01]: me, how many views I'm getting. Because before that I was just like, I don't care. I'm just posting stuff that I like. I think looks cool. And
[SPEAKER_01]: then I had this one that went really well and then I rode the wave and then I grew and then I went, okay, wow. Okay. Now I've got the, okay. Now this
[SPEAKER_01]: seems worth doing. And that was a bit of a game changer for me. Just having one video that did well. What was the amount of likes you were at before
[SPEAKER_02]: that a million viral video and after you eventually rode the wave out for the next two months? What was the difference in the likes or followers in
[SPEAKER_02]: your profile? Not sure. I can't remember, to be honest with you. I probably only had maybe 1,000 or 2,000 followers. And then I had one big
[SPEAKER_01]: video, but then I spent a long time posting after that. I can't remember. It was... It probably took me to 20,000 followers or something, but it
[SPEAKER_01]: wasn't initially off that one video. That one video just gave me the opportunity. It's that one video that went really well. put me, gave me a
[SPEAKER_01]: podium to stand on, to then show all the other stuff that I had to show. And so I got one opportunity that boom, one video went really well. And then I
[SPEAKER_01]: just posted, I can't remember how many people, what the numbers were, but I did do that. I noticed that that happened. I get the vibe. I get the
[SPEAKER_02]: vibe. A question comes to mind. When did the brand start recognizing you? When did it become desirable enough to reach out to Ozone or XCMAG?
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a list of sponsors on your website where you said that, all right, guys, let's try and come together and create something rather
[SPEAKER_02]: than just me doing this by myself. It's a funny one, really, because to be honest with you, my experience with brands, what they want, it's not
[SPEAKER_01]: necessarily how many followers you have. they're not that it depends it depends which brand because obviously like it does help if you've got a
[SPEAKER_01]: million followers it's going to be better for the brands because you're going to be able to market their products to a wide audience but in
[SPEAKER_01]: reality that's not the be all and end all it helps but it's not the most important thing my experience with brands is that If you create good
[SPEAKER_01]: content, if you're a person that matches the image of their brand and they're happy for you to be a figurehead and market for them and a good
[SPEAKER_01]: image for them, then it doesn't matter so much how many followers you have. What they want is that you make good quality content that displays
[SPEAKER_01]: their product nicely and it's something that's shareable and that they can use. For me, it wasn't like I reached a certain followership that
[SPEAKER_01]: then people started. Because the brands that I work with, they're not so concerned about the amount of followers that I have. What they want is
[SPEAKER_01]: they wanted to... know that i was a good person that made good decisions respected the safety of the sport was respected by my peers people
[SPEAKER_01]: respected me and would listen to me and and i think that's way more important than just looking at the statistics on social media because
[SPEAKER_01]: it's actually when it comes to brand partnerships and things like that then just looking raw statistics of engaged followers or whatever it
[SPEAKER_01]: helps but that's not really what people are looking for so what really got me in and and to make these connections with brands was talking with
[SPEAKER_01]: them having somebody get my foot in the door and having conversations and then them speaking to me and understanding and getting to know me and
[SPEAKER_01]: knowing that I'm a person that they would like to work with and that they would be happy for me to represent their brand more than the social media
[SPEAKER_01]: stuff. Just out of curiosity, let's say if there's somebody, I can take my example. I'm starting out and I'm trying to build up a whole ecosystem
[SPEAKER_02]: around this. What would be a good time to go out and explore brand sponsorships for a creator who is trying to make something in their
[SPEAKER_02]: field? It's never a bad time. As long as you can present yourself that you're a stand-up member of the community that people respect, or you
[SPEAKER_01]: make nice, interesting videos. I wouldn't say to somebody, you need to get at least 10,000 followers before you start. I wouldn't say that's
[SPEAKER_01]: the case at all. I don't think there's any benchmark for that. It's more about how you are as a person, how you interact with people and how much
[SPEAKER_01]: people listen to you and you're a respectable person and likeable person. That's more important. I don't think you should be putting a
[SPEAKER_01]: benchmark on that. But as long as you're a respectable person and people listen to you and you get on well with the brands and you don't have to be a
[SPEAKER_01]: huge social media person. I think I love it the way you're presenting a beautiful side of social media and paragliding, because usually every
[SPEAKER_02]: other aspect of social media, you need to have so many followers, you need to keep on posting toxically, you need to follow all of that. And
[SPEAKER_02]: you're telling me now paragliding is all chill, bro. Even the brands don't care about numbers. Just bring your passion and that's all that
[SPEAKER_02]: matters in here. Like having a massive following helps if you were trying, it's, this is a thing, right? Like realistically, look,
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding is pretty niche. Okay. So there's not a huge, if you're trying to sell a paragliding product and we were talking specifically
[SPEAKER_01]: about paragliding here. You don't need, you don't need a million followers. You can't have a million. If you can't have a million
[SPEAKER_01]: paragliding followers, because there's not a million paragliders. So it's no point. So if you've got 10,000 followers, but those 10,000
[SPEAKER_01]: followers are diehard paraglider pilots, you're way better value than old mate celebrity. Who's got a million followers and none of them
[SPEAKER_01]: paraglide. So it's not, that's what I mean. It's not all about the numbers and it's more, it's a tight-knit community. So as long as you've
[SPEAKER_01]: got respect amongst the community, then I think that's more important than your total following. I quickly want to touch upon TikTok because I
[SPEAKER_02]: saw you're active on that platform as well. And some, when I usually research on how social media works, a lot of people say TikTok following
[SPEAKER_02]: isn't as effective as Instagram. Is that true? Do you find more abstract followers on TikTok than other platforms? It's interesting. I don't
[SPEAKER_01]: really, I'm not super experienced with TikTok. And basically what I do is whatever I post on Instagram, I post it on TikTok. My understanding is
[SPEAKER_01]: that so far is that you have a different audience on TikTok. The people on TikTok, there's probably a little bit of a crossover with Instagram,
[SPEAKER_01]: but it certainly is a different, you get a lot, sometimes younger, but also older. Like you have a mix of ages on TikTok too, but it's just a
[SPEAKER_01]: different platform and people expect a different style of video, perhaps longer, perhaps more personalized, detailed, maybe more
[SPEAKER_01]: behind the scenes sort of stuff. Instagram is more like visual content. Catchy music, stylish, and TikTok's a bit more raw. It's just a
[SPEAKER_01]: different style that people go for. If I was really motivated, I'd make slightly different videos on TikTok than I would Instagram. Takes a lot
[SPEAKER_01]: more time, but yeah, it is a slightly different style of viewing. And I think that's why you do get a different audience, but it's a mix of ages.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I it's something if that's worth doing, you know, if you're going to be posting and doing social media, TikTok is huge. It's huge. It has a
[SPEAKER_01]: huge amount of people on it and it's worth posting there. And another point that's worth mentioning as well is TikTok pays. They pay per view.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow. Yeah. So you get, same on Facebook pays per view as well. Instagram, you don't get paid anything. You don't get any money from Instagram. You
[SPEAKER_01]: can get money from, sorry, through Instagram, you can get paid. They can, people can gift you or they can, you can do a subscription service,
[SPEAKER_01]: but Facebook pays you per view because they put adverts on the reels and TikTok does the same. And you can make good money on TikTok. people and
[SPEAKER_01]: that's what a lot of people do and that's why it's worth considering because it's the pay-per-view on facebook isn't that far off youtube
[SPEAKER_01]: yes wow are you telling me that revenue models of facebook and youtube are competing with each other so you can definitely get paid the most per
[SPEAKER_01]: view is youtube but but the thing with facebook is you get it's much easier to Get more views. So maybe you only get 30% per view on Facebook,
[SPEAKER_01]: but you reach a much wider audience. It gets displayed a lot because a lot more people are watching Facebook on their phone. So you may get paid a
[SPEAKER_01]: third, but your video will be viewed 10 times as much. So yeah, it's interesting. It's interesting for sure. Something to consider. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: TikTok and Facebook pay-per-view. I feel like you'll be coming out with a masterclass on how to do social media and adventure sports here. When
[SPEAKER_02]: does the money start trickling in? What kind of number on views are we looking at to bring in some sort of income? It really depends. There's a
[SPEAKER_01]: lot of metrics that go on. you you get pay-per-view but the amount that you get paid per view depends on a couple of factors on youtube it's how
[SPEAKER_01]: many times people who are presented with your thumbnail click on the thumbnail for all of the platforms it depends on the percentage of time
[SPEAKER_01]: that people watch your video if they only watch the first 10 and turn it off you get paid less than if they were to watch the whole thing through
[SPEAKER_01]: another metric is how long the total hours of all the people that are watching your video watch it that basically the longer you can keep
[SPEAKER_01]: people looking at their phone the more money you get so that that's the sim that's the most simple way to look at it if you can whether it's number
[SPEAKER_01]: of views or hours or time percentage but there's a few metrics so you can't put your finger on exactly how much you're going to get
[SPEAKER_01]: pay-per-view but that's the nuts and bolts of all the platforms pretty much yeah Since we are talking about this, I have to put it out there that
[SPEAKER_02]: for me, this is such a big conflict of interest. Because all of us out there know social media does add to depression, anxiety, and
[SPEAKER_02]: everything that comes with it. And yet, we like it or not, just to be a part of the race of capitalism, we have to be a part of the machinery that
[SPEAKER_02]: promotes it. Because that is the only way to go ahead and make something meaningful in this landscape, which is dominating the revenue
[SPEAKER_02]: generation in today's world. So the way that I process it and I really find, because you go through, like I've said before, you go through
[SPEAKER_01]: waves of motivation of why you make these videos and what makes it, because man, I don't make good money from it. I'll be honest with you,
[SPEAKER_01]: straight up. I'm not, this isn't a full-time living. I still have a day job. Like I'm, yeah, maybe I have a good following on Instagram, but I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: not rich. Like it doesn't, Instagram makes no money. This is the reality. And then you have to go back to like, why are you making these
[SPEAKER_01]: videos? And am I making these videos so that people are glued to their phone all the time? No, I'm making these videos because I'm making
[SPEAKER_01]: people aware that paragliding is a thing and it's a cool sport. And I want more people to get in involved and give it a go. And one negative comment,
[SPEAKER_01]: a callback to the previous question that I've had is that somebody commented, and I really enjoyed responding to this. Someone
[SPEAKER_01]: commented, please stop promoting the sport. We don't want more people doing it. They're going to ruin it for everyone. And I just thought
[SPEAKER_01]: you're an absolute more and absolutely not. No, no, I completely disagree with that. I want as many people to start paragliding as
[SPEAKER_01]: possible because we have power in numbers and also it's amazing. I really love it. It's an amazing sport and I think everyone should be
[SPEAKER_01]: doing it because I love it to bits. I think it's great. And also, if more people do it, the more sway we have. And look at Switzerland. They've got
[SPEAKER_01]: a picture of a paragliding on the money, for God's sake. Yeah, the 50 franc note. Exactly, the 50 franc note. There's a picture of a
[SPEAKER_01]: paraglider. And the flying in Switzerland is amazing because... They have good bargaining power with the civil aviation authority. They
[SPEAKER_01]: have air spaces that are open specifically for free flight, hang gliding, glider flights. They take these things into account. If we had
[SPEAKER_01]: a huge flying community internationally, we'd have more sway in how airspace is shaped and how we're considered towards it. And we can only
[SPEAKER_01]: make things better by power in numbers. And I think it's really cool. So I don't think there should be any negativity towards more people taking
[SPEAKER_01]: up the sport. It just doesn't make any sense to me. Yeah, I've faced this dilemma and question myself. And I was like, bro, if people before us
[SPEAKER_02]: thought the same, then we would be still on the ground. The only reason why we are getting the art of flight is because somebody thought they
[SPEAKER_02]: wanted to share with a broader audience. And the only way to do more good in the world is to spread what you're getting. So to me, that doesn't make
[SPEAKER_02]: either sense at all. But yeah, I can imagine. It's quite funny putting sense into people's head like this. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, when we're talking about time, effort and wave of motivation, I really have been curious about editing and post-production because
[SPEAKER_02]: doing all the recording is the fun part. That is effortless because that is where we are living our dream. And then comes the screen time before we
[SPEAKER_02]: are able to share it. Just take us through your editing process. Let's talk about the short form first and then we'll go back to YouTube and why
[SPEAKER_02]: you eventually thought it was not worth it. For social media, when I'm posting on Instagram and things, it's like a minute and a half long, or if
[SPEAKER_01]: it's a story, it's even less. I can do most of that just on my phone. And that's what I did over the last year, especially when I was traveling
[SPEAKER_01]: through Europe, Pakistan, and India, Canada. I was just doing everything on my phone. It takes me an hour and a half, two hours max to put
[SPEAKER_01]: a one to one and a half minute video together. And that's fine. And that's why I do more and more of it. The YouTube stuff takes way longer. It does
[SPEAKER_01]: also depend on whether I'm doing any hyperlapse. I've done some hyperlapses in the past, which is a lot more time consuming because it's
[SPEAKER_01]: a huge video file. i film in 5.7 or 8k and it records the whole time so the computer takes time for it to process you have to create proxy files so
[SPEAKER_01]: that you're in order you're able to edit it without any lagging so there's some stuff that just takes time that i don't have to be set at the
[SPEAKER_01]: computer but i have to set it up and the computer has to do the work for a while do i so with the hyperlapse i record the whole flight Then I have to
[SPEAKER_01]: get the footage onto the computer and I keyframe the whole flight. And then I export the whole flight in a flat aspect ratio in 4K. Then I take the
[SPEAKER_01]: 4K and I proxy all of the footage so that it's a low resolution file that I can then edit with. then i speed ramp all of it and then i export it with the
[SPEAKER_01]: original footage and it's a huge process and it takes time and that's why i've moved away from that because the time that goes into it is just it's
[SPEAKER_01]: just too much and then at the end of the day i'm doing this because i enjoy it and when it becomes too much like a job then it just doesn't seem just
[SPEAKER_01]: not into it but yeah editing for the social media do it on my phone from anywhere in the world it's fine i do also make some of the social media
[SPEAKER_01]: stuff on my computer because it increases the quality i can make better shorter videos faster on my computer when i'm at my computer but if i'm
[SPEAKER_01]: traveling that i don't bring i don't bring my computer with me i just leave it at home but yeah Let's talk about editing GoPro the whole day
[SPEAKER_02]: into 90 seconds, because let's say you record maybe five minute clips or two minute clips, depending upon the time of the flight. And then at the
[SPEAKER_02]: end of the day, you're landed, you have your GoPro and the phone ready to be paired. To me, that just looks like so much work to transfer all the
[SPEAKER_02]: GoPro and then, as you said, keyframe them or cut them shorter. So just talk us through the process from six hour flight to 90 minutes. What are
[SPEAKER_02]: the steps involved? So luckily as a tandem pilot, I'm well trained on transferring GoPro footage to phones. I do it for money every day. But
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah, you get these. This is one here. This is a USB-C micro SD card reader. So I just take the micro SD card out of the GoPro and plug it
[SPEAKER_01]: straight into my phone. And it transfers. And I have an iPhone, but it's USB-C. And the transfer on USB-C, whether you have Android or iPhone, is
[SPEAKER_01]: fast. So I can take all the footage off the GoPro, put it directly on my phone within a minute. The other thing I do is that when I'm filming, so
[SPEAKER_01]: with the software that I use on my phone, the app that I use is called CatCut. You've probably heard of it. It's a popular video editing app on
[SPEAKER_01]: your phone. And then on the computer, I use Adobe Premiere Pro. Both softwares transcribe footage, and you can delete pauses. So what I do is
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a quick capture mode on the GoPro, which is when you press shutter button on the top, turns on, it starts recording. Turns on, starts
[SPEAKER_01]: recording, and when I see something cool, I see something worth looking at, or I'm in a good or an interesting moment or in a scenic moment, I talk.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when I talk... It marks the footage. And this is when I go back to edit later, I drop all of the footage into the timeline and I just delete the
[SPEAKER_01]: pauses because it transcribes the whole sequence. So it just deletes the bits that I'm not talking. And that cuts my footage down by about 80%
[SPEAKER_01]: to just the talking. And then I just take that talking and then I just sift through the words that mean nothing. And then, or it tells the story and I
[SPEAKER_01]: just, I just, and then I just delete, delete, delete bits until I have the right length that I'm looking for. Sometimes I shift some of the video a
[SPEAKER_01]: little bit. So the audio, or maybe I have a really nice audio, but I didn't quite get the right shot. So I shift the video slightly to certain
[SPEAKER_01]: matches, but mostly, um, I talk when I see something cool. And so I put a few videos out that it's just me going, wow, beautiful. Wow. Look at
[SPEAKER_01]: that. And it's because I don't know what to say because I'm not, I know this is a man and I'm just like caught up in the moment. And I'm just like,
[SPEAKER_01]: wow, this is beautiful. Wow. Look at that. Because I know that later, uh, I'm just going to cut to that point because I just have to say something
[SPEAKER_01]: because I know, wow, this is amazing. I need to look at this later because this is spectacular. And that's why I got a bunch of videos. It's just me
[SPEAKER_01]: saying, wow. I kid you not, Benjamin, those compilations of wows and look at that is so infectious to look at. It puts a smile on the viewer's
[SPEAKER_02]: face. And believe me, your wow is going to get famous. So you might think of trademarking the way of saying wow. And look at that in panaglyphic.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's good to hear because I was, I used to always wonder, I was like, how does he not run out of breath? Like his voice is so consistent
[SPEAKER_02]: throughout the 90 seconds. And now it's like, all right, it's the cutting. Editing magic. I love it, man. Thanks for being so honest and
[SPEAKER_02]: transparent with your... secrets behind the camera. So I'm pretty sure a lot of people out there are getting motivation from this and will be
[SPEAKER_02]: following your footsteps. But Benjamin, let's talk about the gear. How did you progress? Because this is one of the biggest things that comes to
[SPEAKER_02]: a creator's mind. All of us want to have the fanciest gear because supposedly that looks the best, but resources are limited for
[SPEAKER_02]: everyone. And so how did you prioritize? How was your journey with gear and investing money in that sense? With camera equipment, Yeah,
[SPEAKER_02]: camera, audio, and investing in any softwares or anything like that. I just always use GoPro, really. GoPro for filming on my head. I've used,
[SPEAKER_01]: and I'm a sucker. I'm a sucker. Like most people, I'm an absolute sucker for new gear. I like to have the latest one or at least try it. And for me, it
[SPEAKER_01]: makes sense because I use it for work, especially for flying tandem. It's good to have the latest camera. You know, the clients are paying
[SPEAKER_01]: good money for the photos, so I like to have the latest camera. But they also come with good new features. But I've always done GoPro. I use 3.5mm
[SPEAKER_01]: GoPro of branded microphone adapter and a Rode Lav 2 wide microphone. And then it's been compatible for the last five years. GoPro since I've
[SPEAKER_01]: used the same one and, and I use it at 360 camera, Insta360. I never used the GoPro Max. I always just used Insta360. I'm using it less and less at
[SPEAKER_01]: the moment just cause it's a lot more admin. But yeah, I just, it's the gear's not super complicated. that getting good audio came from a wired
[SPEAKER_01]: microphone that plugs directly into the GoPro. I do have these new microphones that I use more now just for stuff that I'm doing on the
[SPEAKER_01]: ground. But as I'm sure you're aware, when you're out on a Volbiv trip and flying, weight is important i've got to carry that bag up to hell so i'm
[SPEAKER_01]: not walking around with boom mics you know like a wired lav mic and a gopro is it does the job it's not too heavy and the gopros take amazing footage
[SPEAKER_01]: they film 5.3k and the the color correction that it does on it in itself and and the stabilization takes amazing footage like it is really i
[SPEAKER_01]: can't knock it There are other cameras out there that I haven't tried. DJI makes 60. I've got the action camera as well. I had a play around with
[SPEAKER_01]: the DJI one in the shop and I wasn't blown away by it, but the three, the GoPros are, Good. One caveat I'd say is that you don't always need the
[SPEAKER_01]: latest and greatest with the GoPro because they do bring them out every year for the sake of bringing them out. Like the difference in video
[SPEAKER_01]: quality between the 12 and the 13 is negligible. Like I've owned both and I can't say that the difference is worth the upgrade. The main upgrade
[SPEAKER_01]: worthy thing on the 13 versus the 12 is it's got a magnet. They've now have a magnet. latch mount so you don't have to do the thumb screw whenever you
[SPEAKER_01]: want to change where the gopro is you previously would have to unscrew it every time now you don't it's just magnets it's way better so that's the
[SPEAKER_01]: best thing but the quality of the image is more or less is exactly the same in fact the 13s may be slightly worse just because you've got less you've
[SPEAKER_01]: got less options yeah with the gear it's not super complicated and with the phone the phones take amazing footage modern phones now if you have a
[SPEAKER_01]: new iphone new android they all film 4k they have stabilization like i i don't fly i don't ever take any proper real cameras with me i never have so
[SPEAKER_01]: like the iphone new iphones new phones and a gopro is what i've been running and it works fine magnet mount that you said of course i saw that
[SPEAKER_02]: when they came out with all the marketing and everything can our sport really make use of it when the collapses and all the violence all the shit
[SPEAKER_02]: hits the fan do you think it'll still stick on absolutely yeah no that thing's not coming off it's solid i use it i use it every day that thing is
[SPEAKER_02]: not coming off you'd have to you'd if you try if you put that magnet latch mount on your helmet and tried ripping it off you'd rip the adhesive off
[SPEAKER_01]: before that latch goes it's not going anywhere and that adhesive's on there i've never lost a gopro like i've full confidence in that latch
[SPEAKER_01]: mount it's not yeah it's solid i use it at work and i've got everything leashed but yeah it's that because it's it says magnet but don't be
[SPEAKER_01]: fooled because it's latched so it's there's you have to in order to disconnect it it's you have to push buttons in like it's You put it on and
[SPEAKER_01]: then it catches. So it's not just held on by a magnet. It's there's a mechanism here. It's not coming off. It's a clip on basically. And then
[SPEAKER_01]: yes, exactly. But it's super easy to take it on and off. And for me, it's perfect because when I I'm walking up the hill, And I maybe have a clamp
[SPEAKER_01]: mount and I have the GoPro on the clamp mount. And then I need to swap from the clamp mount to my helmet and it's on. And do you know what? It
[SPEAKER_01]: encourages me to film more because a lot of times I can't be bothered because I've got to unscrew it. And that's a big part for me is that I do
[SPEAKER_01]: this sport because I love it and it's fun. And I don't want it to become, I'm doing this because I'm making a video. I'm doing this because I love
[SPEAKER_01]: flying. And the videography is just something that I do as well. And this is actually maybe a point that's worth touching on because I've flown
[SPEAKER_01]: before with cameras and 360 cameras hanging off the side of me and creating hyperlapses and stuff like that. They create really nice
[SPEAKER_01]: images and videos. And I've got, you know, this camera on and another camera here. And yeah, it makes nice videos, but in reality, it just
[SPEAKER_01]: takes too much away from the experience and you have to find a balance. And that's why I've actually taken a step back in the amount of videos
[SPEAKER_01]: that I'm recording and the amount of cameras that I've got hanging off me because this camera maybe takes, I have to plug a 20,000 milliamp
[SPEAKER_01]: battery into and a one terabyte micro SD card in order to film the whole flight. And it's awkward on the takeoff. Maybe you got a different
[SPEAKER_01]: challenging launch. You've got your brake line wrapped around it. Like it adds risk in it and it's hanging outside the whole time and it spoils
[SPEAKER_01]: your view. And I've been down that path and yes, it does make cool videos, but in reality, it just, for me, I found that I had to take a step back. I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: just, I'm putting too much in the effort of trying to capture videos and it's taking away the enjoyment and the real passion of why I'm doing it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you've got to have a balance. And for me, that meant taking a step back from that. And now I just do more stuff just on the helmet. Super easy,
[SPEAKER_01]: man. I forget the camera's on there. Camera's on my head. Turn it on and start recording. and turn it off, boom, just me flying again. And when
[SPEAKER_01]: you've got other stuff hanging off, it's just too much. And I get a lot of people messaging me, asking me, how do you attach a 360 camera and make
[SPEAKER_01]: these hyperlapses? And I'm like, okay, I'll tell you, I'm happy to tell you, but please let me add the caveat that I don't recommend it. And I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: not just saying that because I don't want you to make the same videos as me. I don't care. It's just, it's risk. There's risk involved. Your
[SPEAKER_01]: takeoff is not going to be as safe and it's a big faff. Like it's just be aware before you spend a thousand euros buying a camera and all the crap.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like it's not the nicest to fight with. Just as for the listeners, like I'm happy to tell people how to do it, but it's, it's, it's normal on
[SPEAKER_01]: social media. I agree. And next time somebody asks you how to make magic happen, you can send them the link to this podcast because that is the
[SPEAKER_02]: whole idea of doing this. I'm so glad you mentioned the risks that come with all of this. But let's say managing risks of having camera
[SPEAKER_02]: equipment versus enjoying the rewards of flight. how you eventually found a fine balance. But for anybody, especially the new beginners out
[SPEAKER_02]: there, especially the ones who are experiencing the art of flight for the first time in their lives, they're super excited to share. I was no
[SPEAKER_02]: different. I wanted a GoPro on my first flight and my instructor was like, no, that is not coming on until you have quite a good control over
[SPEAKER_02]: your wings and everything. The question that I'm curious about is that how do you manage to not do something out of your comfort zone for the sake
[SPEAKER_02]: of the video? Be it placing a mount at a place or be it chasing something which looks amazing or that side of things. How do you look at that? You
[SPEAKER_01]: really have to disconnect. You have to, you know, you have to forget that you have the camera on really. If you, the dangerous part is you get into,
[SPEAKER_01]: and it's never really been an issue for me, but I can see how it could be an issue for some people is that they're making decisions based on the fact
[SPEAKER_01]: that they have a camera on and they want to do something cool because they've got a camera on and they want to, you have to completely
[SPEAKER_01]: disconnect that. The other thing I'd say is that if you're learning and you're in school or just fresh out of school, don't wear a camera. It's no
[SPEAKER_01]: point. Yeah, maybe you want to capture the moment and get someone on the ground to film you because you're not going far. You're a beginner. Just
[SPEAKER_01]: in reality, you need to focus. The biggest risk and the highest incidents are people when they're right at the beginning and they're
[SPEAKER_01]: fresh. And you need to be focusing on flying and doing your thing. You don't need to be making videos. like i said you're not going far get
[SPEAKER_01]: someone to film your takeoff from the ground get someone to film your landing you don't need to be wearing a camera or holding a selfie stick or
[SPEAKER_01]: anything like that you shouldn't even be thinking about holding a selfie stick until you've got a few hundred hours under your belt
[SPEAKER_01]: because you've got to fly with one hand and it's just a lot going on helmet cams i think pretty pretty good if you stick a helmet camera on your
[SPEAKER_01]: helmet I don't think the risk is that huge. You can turn it on, start recording. It's pretty, pretty simple. Maybe you have some risk on the
[SPEAKER_01]: takeoff of your, I've never, it's never been an issue for me. I've literally on takeoff, never got my helmet camera stuck in the lines or
[SPEAKER_01]: anything like that. So I don't think that's a justified risk. Maybe if you're flying aerobatics and you're falling through the lines, it
[SPEAKER_01]: could be an issue. Yeah. I've gotten the camera stuck in the lines after landing, but not on takeoff. But yeah, in the beginning, just focus on
[SPEAKER_01]: flying. Focus on the enjoyment and don't let it distract you. Don't let videography or filming during flight distract you from what you're
[SPEAKER_01]: doing because it's amazing. It's really good fun and really it's about the flying, not about the video. Makes sense. I do have a little bit of a
[SPEAKER_02]: different thought about GoPro on the helmet, though, because first of all, I just hate that they're so heavy and they just add on a little bit
[SPEAKER_02]: extra weight, which you will get used to eventually. I know that subconsciously. I don't even know. This is the funny thing. I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: completely guilty of this because I've always had a GoPro on my head. I have no idea. Interesting. Yeah. And the second one could be a
[SPEAKER_02]: hypothetical situation, but you always consider all the scenarios. And what scares me the most is, God forbid, if it goes in your lines and the
[SPEAKER_02]: glider reopens, it's going to snap so hard on your helmet that it could actually impact you. some kind of neck structure or something in spine
[SPEAKER_01]: that if the glider closes... I think the adhesive will break before your... or the line would break before you'd actually do damage to
[SPEAKER_01]: yourself, to be honest with you. I wouldn't personally be that worried about it. The problem is that it would maybe affect... If you really got
[SPEAKER_01]: stuck in the lines, it could affect the way that the glider flies, but you can always dump the chin strap, but I just never... It's never for me...
[SPEAKER_01]: I've probably... flying with a helmet cam on for over, definitely over a thousand hours, maybe 1500 hours that I've actively been doing it. I
[SPEAKER_01]: have never got my head stuck in the lines. So I can't say yet for that. I definitely, there are risks of making videos in flight. I think the
[SPEAKER_01]: biggest one is taking your hands off the controls. Maybe it's probably the biggest risk to try and mess around with the camera, but actually the
[SPEAKER_01]: risk of getting your head stuck in the lines of the camera on. Yeah, I don't think that's the biggest risk. I think the biggest risk is the
[SPEAKER_01]: distraction. You're being distracted from the flight and your decision-making, and you're not thinking straight because you've got
[SPEAKER_01]: a camera on your head and you're thinking about the camera. Think about the flight. That's the biggest risk. I love your unfiltered honesty,
[SPEAKER_02]: man. I wish every single guest on this podcast was that. But yeah, usually our community is full of people like this. Thank you for your
[SPEAKER_02]: point of view. Quickly, before we wrap up, Benjamin, I have this tradition of asking my guests to share one memory or one experience from
[SPEAKER_02]: their airtime which has stuck with them and which they would like to bring out to the audience. So does anything ring a bell which you would
[SPEAKER_02]: like to talk about right now? Do you know what? It's difficult because there's so many really good flights that I've done over the time. What's
[SPEAKER_01]: the best one? It could be otherwise as well. Like something that just sticks with you, that you revisit often and that the audiences would
[SPEAKER_02]: love to take away from this one hour of a talk. I don't know what's the most sensible. What's the most sensible one for me to bring up? There's one
[SPEAKER_01]: flight. This was probably one of the most exciting moments. And this is actually with the caveat. it was a stupid decision i shouldn't have done
[SPEAKER_01]: this it wasn't sensible but nonetheless it was one of my most memorable flights and one of the most exciting moments that i've had during flight
[SPEAKER_01]: but also an unnecessary risk that i shouldn't have taken and that's the caveat that i'm attaching to it but i was it was a flight this summer i was
[SPEAKER_01]: in switzerland and i had a really beautiful flight we took off from the nice and we flew towards martini and we went around the corner Flew into
[SPEAKER_01]: Vallis and I'm living in the Lauterbrunnen Valley and you have to pass the Brighthorn. So you're flying along Vallis and if you want to get back
[SPEAKER_01]: from Vallis to where I was living and we were, we had a party that night in Gimmelwald, you had to pass over this Ridge to get back. The cloud base
[SPEAKER_01]: is. 200 meters lower than the ridge. I'm like, bugger. How am I going to do this? I don't know how I'm going to do this. And it's like a four hour train
[SPEAKER_01]: ride back, which in the scheme of things, having lived and flown in New Zealand for a long time is not a big deal. Four hour train ride. Perfect. I
[SPEAKER_01]: can sit on the train and have a beer. It's all good. But I'm trying desperately to get back. And there was a glacier. There's a glacier. I
[SPEAKER_01]: can't remember the name of the glacier, but it's a really long flat glacier. It's two, one or two kilometers long. And it's slightly
[SPEAKER_01]: sloping up in the direction that I'm going. And I can't see over it. I'm just high enough that I think I can make the glide over. But it's
[SPEAKER_01]: completely in the light. It's really hard to judge your distance from a completely snow-covered glacier because there's no contour. It's
[SPEAKER_01]: just completely white. You don't know how high you are over it. I think I'm high enough. Oh, I don't know. I'm not sure. I'm going to make the
[SPEAKER_01]: glide. And I started making the glide and I'm getting halfway across it. And I'm like, I don't know if this is going to work. And I've got a five to 10
[SPEAKER_01]: K an hour tailwind, but it's slightly sloping up. So if I don't make it. There's no turning around and going back and I'm trying to judge my
[SPEAKER_01]: height over the glacier. And the only way that I can do that is by looking at my shadow. So I'm looking at my shadow and like all the shadows getting
[SPEAKER_01]: too big turn away. Shadows getting too small turn in. And I just did this and I must've cleared that glacier with five meters. And that feeling of
[SPEAKER_01]: elation that I just, I don't, if I'd not made it over, it would have been absolutely shit show. I don't know what, I don't know. It would have been
[SPEAKER_01]: a difficult situation to get out of. But anyway, as soon as I made it over the glacier, I had home on glide. Boom, done. I'm home. I'm at the pub.
[SPEAKER_01]: Done. I'm going to go see my mates. We're going to the party. It's cool. And just that feeling, and I'd scratched before for an hour to get that
[SPEAKER_01]: extra hundred meters so that I could clear it. I really worked. I really worked hard to get that extra hundred meters. And then boom, I nipped
[SPEAKER_01]: through with five meters to spare and I got home and it was just, wasn't the longest fight they ever done. But that one moment I was just super
[SPEAKER_01]: exciting and happy to not land on the glacier and make it home to the pub. Did you have a good night out, though? No, it was good. Do you know what?
[SPEAKER_01]: The adrenaline was going through me for a while. But no, it was probably not the most sensible thing that I did, but one of the most memorable. I
[SPEAKER_02]: was asking, did you have a good night out, eventually, once you went out on the town? Yeah, it was good. It was good. But yeah, I was pretty
[SPEAKER_01]: excited. Yeah, it was good fun. It was good. We had a good catch up with mates and all the guys that I work with. So it was nice. I was happy to make
[SPEAKER_01]: it and not have to miss it and be on the train. I can imagine. I love when we go proximity flying close to the terrain, and especially situations
[SPEAKER_02]: like these, when you're like, oh, I have to just do my weight shift just the right amount so that we are able to... Because I have been in that
[SPEAKER_02]: situation once, not with that high intensity, but I did clear terrain with... almost just a meter. And I was flying the high B, so the glide
[SPEAKER_02]: wasn't even that exceptional. But it does make it all the more worth it once you are successful. But if you're not, the consequences are quite
[SPEAKER_02]: something to remember. Benjamin, I think we have covered up everything that could possibly come to my mind for this curiosity. Is there
[SPEAKER_02]: anything that you might think from your end that the audiences should know about you? Yeah. I think we've covered everything. Yeah, no, I
[SPEAKER_01]: think it's good. And yeah, just get out there and go and fly. And try not to look at your phone too much and go and live it for yourself. That's what
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm saying. No, I love it, man. On that note, Benjamin, how does the future look like? What are we looking to consume and how much
[SPEAKER_02]: awesomeness are you bringing to your screen in days to come? So I'm just like, I love my job. I fly tandem. I do love it. I could see myself doing
[SPEAKER_01]: this for a while, but if I can move the percentage of tandem flying and some solo flying where I make some videos and I can maybe do half and half,
[SPEAKER_01]: that'd be good. At the moment, most of my income just comes from flying tandem. So if I can find a way to monetize the content that I make to make it
[SPEAKER_01]: worthwhile, I can spend a bit more time doing that. I recently just launched Instagram subscriptions. So people that follow me on
[SPEAKER_01]: Instagram can subscribe to get premium content. And I'm going to give that a go for a couple months at least. And just as long as it keeps growing
[SPEAKER_01]: or I get to the right amount of people that I can keep providing content, then. I'll keep going with that, but it's people want to see that bonus
[SPEAKER_01]: stuff. Then I can, it means I can facilitate taking time out of my normal working day to go and make those videos, which I'm super passionate to go
[SPEAKER_01]: and do. Unfortunately, I still need to eat. Yeah. So I need to either fly tandem or do this. I'd like to find a balance. If I can shift a percentage
[SPEAKER_01]: more towards some solo flying and making videos, then that'd be awesome. But at the moment, I'm happy traveling, making videos in my
[SPEAKER_01]: spare time and being in Europe and being in New Zealand and a bit in between. I'm very happy doing that. I live, I'm fortunate. I live a very
[SPEAKER_01]: nice life. It's good. Wow. I'm so glad you recognize it that way. Because after speaking to you for almost an hour, it's very understandable for
[SPEAKER_02]: me to see that you're in a happy place right now. And that is where anyone thrives and grows. So keep rocking, man. You are doing it just the way it
[SPEAKER_02]: is supposed to be. Thank you. No, I appreciate it. I think I just have to bring this up because you mentioned that the subscription video thing
[SPEAKER_02]: that you have, because I was scrolling through your profile. And just for the sake of our audiences, if you go to Benjamin Killett's
[SPEAKER_02]: Instagram, which will be in the show notes and the description, go to the pinned post next to that subscription, which has almost half a million.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm not telling you because the content is same for us paraglider pilot, but God damn it, the comments that non-flyers have put under that
[SPEAKER_02]: video are freaking hilarious to look at, man. Yeah. I respond to them. This is the funny thing, man. Some of the stuff you get put on there, I'm
[SPEAKER_01]: like, I have to have a little bit of self-control sometimes with how I respond to it. It is funny. Yeah. We just don't know what paragliding is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah. That's hilarious. But I think with great power comes great responsibility. I try and behave myself. Awesome, Benjamin.
[SPEAKER_02]: Benjamin, I think on that note, one of the most amazing episodes that I've had on the show so far. So from the bottom of my heart, thank you so
[SPEAKER_02]: much for coming on board and sharing your wisdom. And I cannot wait to share the sky with you one day, I'd say. Absolutely. I'm looking forward
[SPEAKER_01]: to it. Yeah, sky and the screen. I think that's where the magic will happen. Perfect. Thanks, man.